mais d'abord le raz-de-marée attendu a
bien eu lieu plus aucun rendez-vous de
vaccination contre le coc vite 19 n'est
disponible en indre-et-loire 6000 avait
été ouverte ce matin notamment pour les
plus de 75 ans elle les regards se
tournent maintenant vers le vaccin
astrazeneca plus facile à conserver il
va permettre aux médecins de vacciner en
cabinet les premières doses doivent
arriver lundi prochain
hélène chapelet cabinet médical bonjour
dans ce cabinet médical de saint cyr
tout est prêt pour accueillir les futurs
doses du vaccin astrazeneca une salle de
soins commune entre les cinq
généralistes est déjà opérationnel elle
sert actuellement à réaliser des tests
qu vide mais pourrait se transformer en
salle de vaccination le frigo pour
conserver le vaccin est lui aussi déjà
là il ne manque plus que les doses qui
devraient arriver la semaine prochaine
on va avoir donc la première semaine de
livraison du 22 février une dose de dix
vaccins pour la semaine par médecin donc
ici on est cinq médecins on aura 50
doses pour vacciner nos patients la
deuxième semaine enfin la deuxième
livraison qui aura lieu
début mars si on se réfère à ce que dit
la direction générale de la santé on
aura deux à trois doses de dix vaccins
par médecin et par semaine ces vaccins
réservé aux 50 64 ans seront fournis aux
généralistes par leur pharmacien
référent pour l'instant pas question de
faire appel aux officines pour vacciner
elles serviront dans un premier temps
deux plateformes de dispatch et seront
rémunérés 3 euros 45 par flacon délivrés
donc là on a neuf médecins sur deux
cabinets médicaux aux alentours de la
pharmacie qui nous ont contacté en fin
de semaine dernière pour pouvoir
justement comment dès leurs premiers
flacons contenant les dix doses de
vaccin nous on se charge de les
enregistrer sur une plateforme de la rs
ce qui va leur permettre de passer
commande auprès des grossistes qui nous
livrerons en début de semaine prochaine
ensuite on portera les vaccins aux
médecins volontaires
selon les derniers chiffres de la rs au
13 février dernier dans notre région 99
1588 personnes ont déjà reçu leurs
premières doses du vaccin 27 1338 ont
tué les deux doses nécessaires